Thank you, brethren, because you support
the ministry. Now, lot to talk about.
Lot to talk about. First of all, let me
set the record
straight. First of
all, now I want you guys who know about
iPhones, tell me something. Divine
mercy, apologetics, everyone tell me. I
have George Jenko's number. As you can
tell, when we last spoke, if you see my
message in blue, it said delivered.
Okay?
Right now, I called him out at 5:21
p.m., but it doesn't say delivered. And
I gave him over an hour to reach out to
me. Does that mean he blocked me? Look,
it says kept. Kept and then delivered.
That was the last message several weeks
ago. Today, I called him out and I'm
going to play the voice text. It doesn't
show delivered or kept. So, he blocked
me, right? See, this is why now I'm
going to call out Georenko. You're a
coward. You're a fake. You're about the
money and you're about emotion. And
you're using the Lord Jesus Christ to
fatten your pocketbooks. Cuz now I'm
going to call him out because I was told
that he played the victim today. He
played the victim
today and try to indirectly vilify me
because he got pulverized. So now I want
everyone to demand I want him to upload
the discussion. I now want him to upload
the
discussion.
Okay. I want him to upload the
discussion. Thank the Lord Jesus for
discussion with Rocky Baloa. Everyone
saw what I said about him was true. It's
all about feelings. It's all about
emotion. He's a Bible pervert. He
doesn't know the Bible and he's using
the Bible to fatten his pocketbooks.
It's about money. Now, I'm going to call
you out. I'm going to call you out
because I was told I didn't watch it,
but reliable voices told me. He gave the
impression as if I came to debate. He's
not a debater. He's a babe in the faith.
And I came to
debate. Let me set the record
straight. I want now everyone clip this.
And I want everyone to demand. I want
you to upload the
discussion. I want you to upload the
discussion. And I'm going to correct
your lies. You left me no choice. I was
trying to be nice to you,
coward. Okay? I want it uploaded. I want
people to decide. Was I mean or
rude? From what they told me, he said
he's not a debate babe in the faith and
he didn't upload the discussion because
we agreed to it. No, I'm going to now
correct that. I've corrected it, but
I'll correct it again. And then later
on, I guess he took a jab at me because
Rocky Balbo is known for being too nice
and too passive. Too nice and passive.
He's not my cup of tea. Rocky, I love
you, Rocky Balo, but you're not my cup
of tea. Sorry. All right.
Now, here's what I said. Here it is.
Now, clip it. I want you to upload the
discussion. It's got to be uploaded. If
you don't, you're a coward cuz you're
afraid. Okay, here you go. Right here.
Hey, uh, George, people were telling me
you indirectly took a shot at
me, trying to give the impression I was
being
polyical and I'm a debater for some
reason. I hope that's not true, George,
because I'm going to end up calling you
out if that's the case. And I want to
ask you then to upload the video so
people can judge whether what you're
saying about me is true. So did you
throw me under the bus today? Let me
know, George, because I'm about to go
live and I don't want to accuse you of
something that's
false. Did you hear that text? Let me
play it again. I'm going to play both
text messages. Did you hear it? This is
as loud as it gets. Here it goes.
Documentation now. It didn't go through
what time? 5:21 p.m. Here it goes again.
Listen. Hey,
George. People were telling me you
indirectly took a shot at
me, trying to give the impression I was
being
polyical and I'm a debater for some
reason. I hope that's not true, George,
because I'm going to end up calling you
out if that's the case. And I want to
ask you then to upload the video so
people can judge whether what you're
saying about me is true. So, did you
throw me under the bus today? Let me
know, George, because I'm about to go
live and I don't want to accuse you of
something that's false. Okay. Now, the
second clip, I'm gonna play it twice.
God, I'm going live within the hour. So,
if you don't respond back, I'm just
going to have to call you out live,
brother, because I hope you didn't do
that. You threw me under the bus. So,
it'd be nice to hear back from you that
what they're saying is not true.
Okay, one more time.
God willing, I'm going live within the
hour. So, if you don't respond back, I'm
just going to have to call you out live,
brother, because I hope you didn't do
that. You threw me under the bus. So,
it'd be nice to hear back from you that
what they're saying is not true.
Okay. So, notice previous messages said
delivered, kept, right?
These two
nada has in delivered or
kept. Here's the witness. See, I provide
receipts, but I thought being an
Assyrian, I'll give him the benefit of
doubt. Now, I'm going to call you out,
George. You're a coward. You're a fake.
You're not only a disgrace to the
Assyrians, you're a disgrace to the Lord
Jesus Christ. You're a grifter who wants
subscribers and money and you're making
money off of your ignorance of
scripture. The Lord Jesus expose you.
So, I want this to be clipped by all of
you and send it. George, I want you to
upload our discussion. Now, let me
correct another lie because I corrected
it. I'm going to correct it again. See,
I'm getting tired of this, man. I don't
want to be doing this stuff. I got
better things to do. Let me give you the
context of why I said, George, it may
have been God's will for this to be
private for you not to upload the
podcast. Let me now set the record
straight. When we ended it and I ended
it, I ended it because his friend Rob
wanted to argue, didn't answer my
question. I go, I don't want to argue.
Let's end it because I don't want to
engage in foolish quarrels.
So I go, "Unless you have anything new
to say, George, it's over." So we ended
it. But here's the thing. He went to the
what is that? The sound voice, the box.
He says, "24 minutes." I believe he said
24. Now don't hold me accountable. I
remember 24 minutes. I may have been
wrong. So I go, "What happened?" He
goes, "No audio for 24 minutes. It may
have been different time." I got the
impression that the audio went out 24
minutes into our conversation. So then I
looked to his cameraman, three cameras.
I go, "Did this record fully?" "Yeah."
"Did we lose audio?" The cameraman said,
"No, we got it all." I go, "Are you
sure?" But when he said 24 minutes, I
thought he meant 24 minutes into our
conversation, we lost audio. I go,
"Maybe it was God's will for that to
happen so that this would be private.
you don't upload it. But when the
cameraman and then George told me, "No,
the last 24 minutes," I said, "Oh,
good." Because the last 24 minutes was a
waste of time. It was arguing about not
arguing because they didn't want to
answer questions.
Okay. I go, "Okay, then you can edit
that part out and upload all of it cuz
that is still fruitful."
So my impression was the last 24 minutes
superfluous because it was just like
arguing about not arguing and why you're
not answering questions. But that 1 hour
and 10 minutes very fruitful because I
answered every single objection
thoroughly with sound biblical
historical arguments and he kept going
by feelings. So I thought it was going
to be uploaded. So now I know he's a
coward and he didn't upload it because
he would have been
humiliated. His 2.95 million subscribers
would see he's a charlatan, a fraud,
does not know the Bible. He's an
ignoramist who goes by feelings. He's
using the Bible to continue making the
money to get the money rolling in
because he's a fake. You're a fake,
George. It is sad because not only
you're a disgrace to the Assyrian
community, you're a disgrace to
Christianity, which is even sadder. So,
I'm not going to call you out, George. I
gave you time. You must have blocked me
here. George Yenko, here's his
number. You must have blocked
me. I want you to publicly repent and
apologize and upload the video. I want
it because then people will judge
whether I'm the meanie and a baddy. But
I've already read your receipts in the
previous session. Go watch Georgenko. I
did a session. You admit I was very
friendly, bold, decimated your
arguments, but I wasn't rude. I didn't
talk down to you. I called you out for
being affeminite with your emotions in a
nice way. But now I'm going to say
you're affeminite. You're a disgrace.
You really are. Well, I said that,
brother. Go watch the session I did. I
go, can we go live? No. Can I bring
someone? No. And he said, "Can I bring
someone?" I go, "Sure." How is it with
me he brought someone, but with Alex he
had no
one? Yep. Right here. Jeremy just shared
the link. Mga make Rumble great again.
So, I'm calling you out, guys. Flood
his social media. Sam called you out. He
wants it uploaded. No
excuses. Big boy. You lie. You played
the victim. You're all about
emotion. Upload and let my detractor
say, "Cece, he was right. Sam was a
meeting." And for the record, our mutual
friend, Gore Yaru, Assyrian, he reached
out to me whether I discussed with you.
I didn't reach out to you unlike Alex
Rocky Baboa who reached out to you. I
did not reach out to you because I could
care less to discuss with you. And this
is a fact. Rocky Baba, Alex, I pray in
Jesus name he reigns you in. I hope
you're not a cloutchaser and a grifter
that you're calling out everyone with a
platform because you want to make more
numbers. I hope that's not your
intention. May the Lord Jesus reign you
in. You're young. You asked to discuss
with George and go. I didn't I didn't I
didn't
ask I was asked by a friend of his and
mine. Gorillo. I got the
receipts. Now, Alex, you're a Catholic
brother. Rain yourself in. Stop chasing
big names to get platform to get
subscribers. Trust in the Lord Jesus
Christ open doors for you that no man
can shut. Okay. May the Lord Jesus
destroy my flesh, our flesh, destroy sin
in me and forgive me as I acknowledge my
weakness. Have mercy on me and we finish
the race with
integrity. Okay. So, clip this and I'm
saying upload it. I want it
uploaded. No caps, brethren.
And Alex, I hope this reaches you in
Jesus name. May you purify our hearts.
May we practice what we preach. I pray
you're not a grifter and a cloutchaser
that you want to be platform to get more
subscribers. If so, the Lord chase you
in love. You don't need it. Trust God to
open doors for you, young man.
Stop.
Stop. Please. Because you'll see he was
talking about, "Yeah, I'd like to talk
to George Ko." Who is which person would
you not like to talk to? And from the
feedback I'm getting, they say you're
too soft and you let him get away with
murder and arrogance. You're not doing
the Catholic Church a favor,
brother. You're not doing Honestly,
you're not. You guys think you are.
You're not doing the Catholic Church a
favor. Well, brother, I hope I love the
young man. We'll know if he's not a
grifter or clout chaser. Don't let your
emotions get the best of you because you
divine mercy know how I let my emotions
get the best of me with a particular
individual. And we're not going to name
names,
right? See, you see that? How you going
to let him get away? And here a guy
who's not a debater, arrogant
jerk, and then appealing to emotions.
I'm not a debater. And yet you come off
arrogant. Really?
All right.
[Applause]